hello and welcome once again to Android
design in action we have a very special
episode for you today about navigation
drawers of the new pattern introduced at
Google i/o 2013 we have some very
awesome members of the Android design
team they'll introduce themselves in a
moment they're here to talk to you about
the pattern so that's going to go on for
about 20 30 minutes or so and then we're
going to go into a couple of questions
that Nick and I have prepared for the
team about this awesome new pattern so
just to quickly introduce ourselves my
name is Roman Nurik and hi my name is
Nick Miceli from London all right my
name is since noggin interaction design
on the Android design team
rich Fulcher interaction designer on the
Android design team and we're both here
in Mountain View and actually this is
one of my favorite episodes I think so
far because we have folks from Mountain
View New York and London in the same
video hangout at the same time so anyway
without further ado rich Jen's would you
like to take it away sounds great so um
I thought we could start by maybe going
through a little bit of the history of
how the navigation drawer emerged as a
pattern and kind of going back I think
kind of the first app that a lot of
people experienced the navigation drawer
and on Android and certainly the first
Google app they would have seen it in it
was YouTube now that drawer that we saw
saw at that time is different in a lot
of key ways from the drawer pattern that
we discussed last month at i/o but it
was still had a lot of the same original
objectives you know to bring content to
the forefront to get navigation out of
the way and have it only use screen real
estate when the user was kind of
actively trying to change locations so
when we on the design team see a need
like that we kind of have this natural
instinct to want to turn it into a
pattern that other applications can make
use of because we often see that that
need is not specific to a given
application or service but it's
something that would be a benefit to a
larger audience so the first step that
we do is we look at a pattern like that
particularly on Android is we like to
think about how that works from
a navigation standpoint Android as you
know is special in its use of both the
back button and an up affordance in the
very commonly used action bar pattern
and as we are looking at the navigation
drawer there are a lot of different ways
we could have elected to have it behave
in terms of its interaction with those
two controls you know could have been
that the drawer always presented itself
the minute you launched an application
and was kind of a logically a screen
sitting above the other screens well or
it could have been something that was
invoked by one of the in for dances but
not the other you know that up would
trigger it but not back or you could
even have other interactions with back
we're making multiple selections or
sequential selections from the drawer to
build up a continuous back state in the
end we went with kind of a pretty
straightforward model and that the
drawer is invoked off the action bars up
affordance in an altered form and
doesn't relate to the back button except
for closing it but we like to start with
these broad explorations so what you're
seeing on the screen here are some of
really the earliest wireframing work we
did around this drawer pattern in
defining it after we consider the
interaction we like to look at kind of
what the the visual storytelling we're
going to do with these elements could be
and with the drawer we had a lot of
different options even just thinking
about you know what that trigger
mechanism would look like to let the
user would know that there was a drawer
there YouTube first introduced that they
didn't have any kind of distinct graphic
they just relied on the existing left
arrow but we thought about well what if
we did a special icon or a glyph to
decorate the application icon and that
would denote there's a drawer you know
something like the three vertical lines
that we've come to affectionately know
as the hamburger internally here but
there were other options it could have
been that we used a right arrow to
indicate this kind of something was
emerging from the side from the left
side moving to the right or it could
have been a less special treatment that
when triggered used the contextual
action bar flavors so that I could
miss it in the same way that you would
dismiss a selection state again we try
to look at a range of options we always
try to think about many contexts of use
not just one particular application and
we try to look for ways to you know
produce synergy with other patterns that
are already in use both for developers
and for us most importantly for users
who have certain expectations based on
what they've already seen in a platform
you know where we ultimately ended up
was you know what you've seen there's a
distinct icon in the action bar and I
can touch it to open it but we also put
a lot of thought into what the gestural
mechanisms that could be used to open
this should be so we have the edge swipe
available it's really a shortcut at the
top level
it does the exact same action that the
hitting the action bar would do but it
really comes into its own on lower
levels of the application where that
action bar space is being used for
hierarchical up and then the edge swipe
can be an immediate way to access that
control from deeper within the
application all right
the navigation drawer is really you know
a new way of switching top levels inside
of your app there have been already
established patterns in Android such as
the six pack for example the spinner or
the fixed tabs that US developers are
probably very familiar with that serve a
similar purpose let's look at that
really quick basically what they do is
they allow you to switch between the top
levels so if you look at a you know
really you know boiled-down diagram of
an app the top level is basically the
screens that represent the different
facets of your app and they sort of have
the function to represent the major use
cases of your app and sort of guide you
down
through the connecting screens down to
the consumption level what you can see
is that what those patterns have in
common is that they only represent
themselves at the top level so be it the
six-pack or be the the taps that they
all rely on a piece of user interface or
a piece of chrome that lives in
particular at the top level once you
navigate away from that you know that
that switching opportunity goes away
from you and if you want to switch back
to a different facet you actually have
to navigate up to the top level and that
is actually one of the key differences
to the navigation drawer so if you look
here for example the navigation drawer
does include all the top levels though
at the very minimum but it now also can
include screens at the lower levels
so basically we're thinking about those
as navigation hubs basically places that
users would want to often frequently
visit often or use as a jump off point
to other places in the application so if
you wanted to look at you know when to
use the navigation drawer as opposed to
the other patterns that we talked about
earlier here are some some helpful
statements or helpful guides that can
help you make this decision you know one
of those could be more than three top
levels so the navigation drawer is
particularly good at you know showing
more content exposing more content than
the other top level switching mechanisms
if you have more than three top levels
navigation drawer becomes a possible
choice if you have less than you know
you can also look at other top level
switching mechanisms such as taps for
example that are you know very good at
exposing the different facets of your
app you know within one view also if you
have deep navigation hierarchies the
navigation drawer is a good choice and
here's the reason why we've seen that as
you navigate away from the top level
usually in an app that uses the
traditional top level switching
mechanisms you would have to do some
considerable navigation effort to get
back to the top level and then switch
over to a different facet of um the
navigation drawer helps you here in that
it is available from anywhere in the app
and you can just through you know site
swiping gesture bring it on screen and
navigate freely to pretty much anywhere
in the app also if you are your
navigation hubs are at deeper levels the
navigation drawer is a good choice so
for example if you know one of your
facets basically has navigation hubs at
different levels it makes sense to
include them in the navigation drawer in
order to jump quickly into those deeper
levels if you have a need for cross
navigation meaning that you want to
quickly jump from one facet maybe at a
deeper level to another facet that also
has a deeper level navigation drawer
allows you to do that by including those
deeper navigation targets inside of the
drawer since your navigation drawer has
more content the navigation drawer gives
you also options to structure your
content data so you can for example as
we can see here you can add headers
dividers and icons in order to you know
group certain areas of functionality
better we also introduced collapsible
items
those are another means of structuring
your content by you know adding sub
ordinate items typically content items
to you know top-level items maybe a
couple of notes to you know some
interaction details one other thing
about the navigation drawer is that it
does not have a lot of representation on
the screen so if you look at an app that
has a navigation drawer the defining
characteristic is really the navigation
draw icon in the top left so in order
for people to understand how navigation
works in that particular app and that a
navigation drawer is actually present we
wanted to make sure that you know as
people launch an application for the
first time that they are sort of
confronted with the navigation drawer
and sort of see what options they have
what sort of the top level activities
are that they can take advantage on of
in your app so upon first launch open
the navigation drawer people then can
you know navigate freely from there in
your app or just simply dismiss the
navigation drawer and get to the main
content that way once they're beyond
that point once they have actually
opened the navigation drawer manually
for the first time you know on
subsequent launches then you know don't
show the navigation drawer and launch
anymore so in that that way you make
sure that people know that there is a
navigation drawer how to interact with
it well I have favorite things I want to
point out about that was that basically
you know you get the ability to to tell
the user about the gesture and about the
physical space within which the
navigation drawer interacts right so if
you initially show the navigation jar
and then you kind of you know they'd be
hided by either touching outside it's
the content area or
touching the up affordance or anything
like that they basically you know the
navigation drawer immediately slides to
the left and it kind of hints that if
you pull out from the left you'll
actually see it again so it almost hit
hints at the gestures involved with that
kind of initial impression that you get
yeah in that sense it's a really
important learning step right to get you
familiar with what the app is really all
about and also how the navigation drawer
actually works and functions then the
second thing I wanted to point out is to
give the user a peek and that is really
to make the navigation drawer more
detectable and also more tangible if you
use the the library that we provide for
implementing the navigation drawer you
don't really need to worry about this
because that's already automatically
taken care of and you get this for free
but you know what it really does if as
users explore applications with their
fingers and then maybe accidentally
touch on the left edge of the screen
then you know you're draw peeks in a
little bit and sort of gives you a good
affordance of good feedback that you can
drag the navigation draw out from the
left on to the rest of the screen
finally we often get the question well
if I use the navigation drawer should I
have as a navigation drawer icon at all
levels of my app should it be
represented on all screens and the
answer is really no only only those
screens that are represented in the
navigation drawer should actually have a
navigation drawer image all other
screens have the traditional up caret
and the reason for that is really as we
were developing this we sort of
entertained the idea of having access to
the navigation drawer via the
application icon throughout but it
really felt like it creates a separate
brand of
applications with a different navigation
model that is not consistent with other
Android applications that sort of sit
both side by side with navigation drawer
applications so in that sense we four
screens that are not typical jump off
points or are not you know high value
navigation targets we keep the up
affordance there intact
so just to interject there so on those
other screens where you have the other
ones it's still accessible via this kind
of the bezel swipe the edge swipe right
oh yeah absolutely in that way it's kind
of like an accelerator like a keyboard
shortcut so the power users who know
about it like you know you have this
method of easily putting up the
navigation from anywhere everyone while
still retaining the familiar navigation
kind of hierarchical navigation with
yeah right exactly it's good that you
mentioned that so the navigation drawer
is accessible or should be accessible
from from all levels and the navigation
drawer images is really sort of this the
short little reminder that you know the
navigation drawer or they get at a place
where navigating away with the
navigation drawer is a likely option
yeah it's also kind of if you have an
application that just used the up
affordance at that topmost screen that
left pointing caret would go away and
that was kind of an indication to the
user that you are at a special place
here at the kind of logical top of the
application the presence of the three
line drawer indicator does much the same
thing now you're getting a slightly
different look at what the action bar is
and again it's just kind of reinforcing
your you're at the home of the app
you're at this logical place from which
you can go to lots of different
destinations and you can use the drawer
to accomplish that
so now I just like to run through a few
examples and we can talk about some of
the different uses of the drawer and I
thought I would just go through a number
of the Google Apps that have been
recently released that make use of the
drawer and the first one is Gmail which
probably many people are well-acquainted
with in the latest version of Gmail
we've introduced the drawer and the
drawers used kind of for two different
capabilities the most expected one is
that it's used to move between my inbox
and other supporting labels so doing the
same kind of navigation that was
previously available from a spinner in
the primary action bar um it's also
accommodating the ability to switch
between accounts and so kind of at the
top of the drawer you see the radio
button for the currently active account
and we would just kind of introduce more
and more of those if there were more
accounts present using the drawer as an
account switching mechanism is something
that's used by a couple of the Google
Apps and you'll notice in Google Drive
for instance they also support this they
use a spinner within the drawer in that
case because the perception is that
account switching is a less frequently
required task for drive users whereas
for Gmail we have this stronger
presumption of if you have these two
Google accounts and you're likely
checking mail in both of those accounts
so rather than having a two touch
operation of touch on spinner to open
touch on account to transition we want
to expand those account options directly
into the drawer so we use the radio
button approach there the drawer also
makes use of kind of additional content
for the item so you're seeing counts of
unread items for each of the selected
labels again more kind of metadata that
helps guide a user to which destination
they may wish to go to the other thing
that's good to note about the way the
Gmail uses the the drawer is the way
that the action bar transforms when the
drawer is open so in its kind of natural
state when you're looking at the inbox
you have actions for compose or for
search and those are operations that
relate specifically to that account that
you have present you're going to be
generating a new email from that account
be searching the content of that account
because the drawer covers content that
could be from multiple accounts when we
open that Bo's actions are suppressed
and they just you know disappear from
the action bar we always want the
actions that you show with in the action
bar when the drawer is open to relate to
the entire application context so we
just kind of removed those that have a
tighter focus or tighter scope so that
one quick question I guess so here in
Gmail we see the use of standard hallo
list headers to indicate different kind
of segments or different sections of
labels and then above that you obviously
have the account types or the accounts
to choose from whereas you guys also
talked about the the option to have
collapsible items you talked a little
bit about the difference when you would
use one of Rights the other sure sure so
for for Gmail we just kind of expand all
of those items and don't use a collapse
largely because the relative ordering
the items within there could have
naturally supports the most frequently
things frequently used destinations
appearing at the top and then just
supporting it continuous scroll with a
very predictable order to it you know
once I get kind of past my recent or
system level labels I'm it just in an A
to Z listing of all the the labels that
I've created or that I manage so there's
kind of not a lot of need in that case -
since it is really just one collection
that you're opening to have more
fine-grained controls over that
presentation if however you had a number
of such categories you wouldn't want the
user to have to kind of scroll through
this the full contents of the second and
third category to get to the fourth one
and so in those types of situations
compacting makes a lot of sense it's
just kind of you're using the option to
compact or expand those items as a way
to accelerate the user getting to the
the sub items that they need to reach
make sense Thanks sure well we're
talking about kind of having different
groups of content and also the expanding
collapsing pattern do you have any
recommendations about kind of the
maximum size I mean you probably
wouldn't want some kind of unbounded you
know let's
in a navigation drawer right do you have
any kind of guidelines about where where
you might stop yeah I mean I think the
strongest guideline is that you don't
want to kind of try to replicate all the
data that your app is trying to express
inside of the drawer now if you find
that you have a lot of targets but they
have a very predictable ordering to them
so you know you may have a user who uses
you know dozens of labels in Gmail
that's still a fairly suitable usage
because again it's highly predictable
you know exactly what you're going to
get and the content that you're trying
to express Reach is is is kind of pretty
tight it's really just a label and
account for other situations where you
have more content where it's dynamic
where that's changing on a more regular
basis those are the kind of things that
I think work less well as navigation and
it might just be that you kind of need
to pull those out express them kind of
in the full context of your app rather
than just trying to accommodate them
into the drawer and I would say if in
general if you don't fit into this
notion of having kind of categories or
well-ordered sets of content and you're
finding that you have a lot of distinct
navigation you know destinations within
the drawer it might be taking a little
bit it might be worth taking a little
step back and kind of thinking about how
you're structuring your your application
it may simply just be too broad there
might be ways that you could kind of in
a sense lose a little bit of speed of
accessing this wide breadth of options
by adding a little bit more depth here
application and there as a result making
it just kind of more kind of naturally
and easily understood by the user and
taking advantage of the the relationship
between distinct but related
destinations that maybe want to get
presented in a more combined format
further down the hierarchy we've we've
definitely given folks the feedback in
the past that hey your app is doing too
much like focus on the couple of things
that you can do really well and do those
and
obviously then you know your your list
of different sections in the app you
know sure it gets trimmed down to
something smaller and more manageable
but we're definitely even the feedback
that maybe this is multiple apps or
maybe you know you should trim out some
of the functionality nothing on the on
the lower end we talked about you know
three top levels you know as a starting
point of four top levels I should say as
the starting point for using the
navigation drawer you want to make sure
that the navigation drawer is not under
populated so if you for example imagine
you know navigation drawer only having
two items three items it feels you know
too much white space it feels you know
too under populated and there are other
top level switching mechanisms that you
know could be a better choice there
that's actually a great lead-in to the
next example I want to cover which is
the the way that the Play apps make use
of the navigation drawer so what you're
seeing here are the play music in the
Play Books app you know at the left play
music opens up and it has you know five
different navigation options you know
and could add more it's scalable so I
was kind of there more ways of consuming
your music we can naturally suit that in
and that's also I think something that
goes into that decision not just kind of
where you are immediately enter in your
app but what you see the roadmap for the
next version of the version after that
so kind of planning ahead for more
significant navigation needs might also
be a good reason to adopt the drawer you
know slightly early but in this
particular case we've got can somewhat
symmetric ordering of the options
between these two you know different
apps the different focus on different
types of media and they both start with
kind of this now oriented context either
listen now for music or read now for
books they then go into kind of looking
at the way that your library is
structured in ways you can consume it
music has more options in that regard
because it also supports playlists and
instant mixes but it's you know
still those are versions of how is the
content organized and both of these
navigational drawers then terminate with
a shop option which is actually not even
an internal navigation it's a handoff to
the Play Store by presenting those
similar structures in similar orders
between these different but related
applications you're helping the user
build up a good mental model of what
they expect a play app to feel like and
how they can kind of quickly learn ways
to navigate them and apply what they
learn in one context to another one of
the nice side effects I guess of having
shop open up the Play Store is that
actually the Play Store also uses the
kind of the branded single accent color
action bar like once you jump into the
shop for books area you actually get a
blue action bar with a books icon and so
on actually notice the play icon at the
top left but there is some kind of
persistence of state you're not jumping
into a completely separate experience
that's it's still kind of part of the
same family of products yes definitely
and then you're you're kind of back
navigation away has some interesting
effects there as well
so mm-hmm the next example I want to
look at was Google Earth and which has
some slightly non-traditional usage of
the the navigation drawer but I just
wanted to kind of talk about this a
little bit because I think it's it's
interesting the first thing I'll point
out is that Earth doesn't use a proper
action bar and it's because it's a very
search focused activity it uses that
real estate that you would expect an
action bar to use at the top to present
a field where the kind of the user can
always touch and to put in a destination
that they'd like to refocus that view
upon and it doesn't have kind of the
standard you know actions or overflow at
the right-hand side the normal action
bar would present but it still can
present the app icon and it can present
the glyph indicating the presence of the
drawer and then touching that
effectively leaves the action bar in
place again some action bar but it's
giving it that same kind of stability
that the drawer would expect and just
kind of sliding the content
of the drawer and sitting properly
beneath that I'm pseudo actionbar Earth
uses the navigation drawer not so much
for navigation although does have
elements of that in that Earth gallery
target at the bottom is a proper
navigation link but it's using it to in
effect filter the view or set
preferences about the level of detail
that you want to see in the primary view
another option for this would have been
to continue to use the drawer pattern
but to rely on a right-hand side drawer
instead of kind of trying to present it
in the traditional navigation space you
could present it at right and make it
more about filtering but it's there are
trade-offs involved in that as well in
terms of you know how you indicate the
presence of that drawer and how that
would affect the action bar and even the
branding and that comes with having the
app icon at the top
relatedly if you look at the Google one
today application this is an application
that's focused on charitable giving and
encourages users through a notification
to make a dollar donation every day to
various organizations and efforts it
uses both a left and a right drawer and
I think it does a really excellent job
of it the left drawer is standard
navigation you open it up and you can
move between kind of either looking at
the current offer or other things like
looking at a profile kind of your giving
history the right-hand side drawer is
focused on notifications and it's
invoked either by a right edge swipe and
right to left edge swipe or by touching
on the notification count action in the
action bar and touching there does the
exact same animation you would see so
you'd see it kind of slide in from the
side and the same your teaching you
again that you can probably perform this
gesture to invoke it using the animation
to tell that story to the user about how
that drawer performs and these drawers
actually can move directly from one to
the other as well which is you know you
can have it to play to play with it to
see the effect but it's it's really
neatly done they kind of chase each
other at
proper speed and the animations well
implemented awesome so I think that's
all the guts all the content you know
the pre-canned content you guys had
about navigation drawers and obviously
for folks that are looking to implement
this a couple of quick points all the
design guidelines are available on
developer.android.com slash design slash
patterns slash navigation badge are
something like that just go to the
design site you'll see it there and the
second thing is if you're a developer
looking to implement this Nick and I
actually did a an i/o presentation on
navigation drawers
I sure we did we talked about other
things as well but the Android design
for UI developers presentation has
implementation tips and also rich and
Yin's you guys did a presentation at i/o
about structure and app design right so
this is also well covered there so lots
of good resources outside of this video
if you're looking to employ so think we
have about we have a few minutes left we
should probably go through a couple of
questions I know there's some burning
hot questions from community that I
wanted to ask you guys we probably have
time for like three or four and let's
let's like I start with one of the
popular ones so a lot of the community
implementations of navigation drawers
out there actually rather than
overlaying content they slide it out of
the way or I guess they kind of push it
to the side you know some push the
action bar some don't but our our
pattern our implementation actually
overlays the content you guys talked a
little bit about the reasoning and beat
on the decision making process for that
sure um let me break it into two parts
because I think there's kind of two
interesting things that we were looking
at you know pretty extensively during
our exploration of this the first is the
question of keeping the action bar in
place and that was a decision we would
come to fairly quickly we thought there
was a lot of value to kind of even as
that drawer component comes in keeping a
stable element that just really speaks
to the identity and the context that
you're currently within within the
application it gave us the ability to
transform the action set to open up and
show actions that
you know maybe weren't in the immediate
context but had global relevance to the
app and could be you know convenient
accelerators for things you would want
to do from any context so we very early
on latched on to the idea that we'd want
to keep the actionbar president and we
definitely looked a lot at should we
push the content or should we slide the
panel over I think we had a kind of a
gut instinct that we thought slide was
going to be interesting because of the
desire to as Yin's talked about before
bringing the drawer in from kind of
deeper levels of the hierarchy that even
when the affordance wasn't there you'd
want to be able to bring the drawer in
and I felt more natural to us to think
of it sliding over as opposed to kind of
existing to the left of all these
different spaces of hierarchy and and
kind of more thinking and more
experimentation with that led us to just
as we were playing with these different
prototypes we always put a strong focus
on the importance of direct manipulation
to the user that we want them to feel
like you know when their finger goes
down on a device and they start moving
in it that the content is really
strongly anchored to that and responding
directly if we were to do the push there
are some conditions where that wouldn't
feel that that way so you know if it's
that I have my main screen and then
beside it the drawer sits and it's just
kind of slightly off screen well if
those two are really married together in
that way then you would expect that a
drag a kind of a pull on that main
surface would bring the drawer in
naturally if we were to do that then you
wouldn't be able to do the swipe to do
any other action within that main view
you couldn't use kind of a view pager
you couldn't use swipe to dismiss you
know in the earth example you couldn't
even pan within the view of the the
globe that you're seeing there yeah so
you know we didn't want to kind of set
up this relationship that didn't feel
authentic and feel true for all these
manipulations so by saying no it's an
edge swipe and that's pulling it and
it's just pulling this surface and not
affecting the one that you're not
we felt like that gave the most direct
feedback and just simply felt the best
to users as we experimented with it and
I also think that that it somewhere the
heather has a more non-modal feel to it
in that you know it feels like a like a
little navigation helper that you that
you can pull on screen that does not
give you the impression that you know
this level that you're pushing out of
the way is directly linked to the
content that you're pulling onto the
screen so the to only have an indirect
hierarchical relationship right whereas
if you push the content other way they
sort of feel like they're stuck together
and and one is directly subordinate to
the other and that sort of would not
work if you pull in something from the
lower levels of the screen as Richard
pointed out earlier make sense next if
you have any questions yeah I only
sauced a little bit more about kind of
right-hand roll as you touched on it a
little bit in the end talking about
earth and one today and but it's not
saying we've particularly documented in
the in the design guidelines so the way
I see is we're kind of sticking to the
general arrangement with the action bar
so navigation is always on the left and
actions tend to be on the right hand
side so that's the way you see a
breakdown so you could every legitimate
to use left-hander and a right-hander or
one or the other yeah so definitely as
we've seen in the in the example with
Google Earth you know one one option
could have been to you know take all the
settings content which is not directing
navigation content move it over to the
right but you know for me I you know
sometimes break it down as you know
things on the right you know the actions
or settings that usually are in the
overflow they're contextual to the to
the view right so if I
pull in something from the right invoke
an action or you know two customizations
of a view there they're all directly
related to the view that I'm currently
looking at whereas navigation is more
more at a meta level it helps me to
reach the different destinations inside
of my app whereas the the right-hand
stuff sort of manipulates the stuff that
I'm currently looking at cool so I had
two more questions I'll ask the first
one first I guess so Google Hangouts is
another application that was released
recently and it actually uses something
that is some similar somewhat similar to
the navigation drawer but it's different
so for developers out there it's really
the difference between draw or layout
and sliding pane layout so can you guys
talk a little bit about the difference
between something like a navigation
drawer and something like what Google
Hangouts uses to kind of have lists on
the list of stuff on the left and
details on all right sure sure I mean I
think the the easiest way to kind of
think about that difference is to kind
of take a slight step back and think
about how what function the different
elements are trying to perform within
each of those contexts so the
traditional navigation drawer is in a
sense it's I want to get away from the
current current context and I want to go
somewhere else you know what's currently
here isn't interesting anymore so I want
to go elsewhere for hangouts it's a
slightly different case and for a few
reasons one is that kind of the two
panes that are interacting for those who
haven't used it and it's kind of a list
of all the conversations that I have
ongoing and then that intersects with a
detailed view of a given conversation
which kind of appears to slide in front
of it but leave a slight edge of the
conversation view conversation lists
simile in place that list of
conversations is not as simple as a set
of data objects as a normal navigation
view drawer would use you know it's not
just a label and you know perhaps
account it's you know who is in this
conversation it's an icon that might be
an aggregate of up to four different
participants
a snippet of when the last of what the
last message was and who said it if it's
an image it could be a preview of the
image if there's a ongoing video hangout
that's there that may be indicated it
may be time stamped it has kind of a
read unread status so there's actually a
lot of data that every item in that
conversation list is communicating and
it's completely dynamic you know you can
swipe it away you can have archived
conversations new conversations can come
in conversations can reorder and all of
those things make it can significantly
distinct from what we would
traditionally use a navigation drawer
for so because of those reasons you know
we wanted to still have that sense of
the relationship between the panel and
the notion of even when I'm within the
detail view of one particular hangout I
can still see what's going on in those
other hangouts especially on tablets and
larger form factors I can get the sense
of oh there's a new message here because
that moved up and there's a new person
talking there perhaps and these other
ones are just decaying and they're not
having anything interesting happen to
them so can it have those properties of
more information dynamic content and
just the ability to kind of peek even
without having to pull the drawer in on
some devices that made it kind of you
know in our estimation best to use a
variation in the sense of that pattern
rather than just going ahead and just
using the drawer or just using a simple
hierarchic list where there's no
distinct relationship we want to create
a relationship between those two spaces
but not quite as strong as as the drawer
okay it actually folds them very nicely
into my last question that I had so you
know some some people some folks may
need or may find themselves in cases
where they they need some sort of a kind
of dynamic items so for example let's
say I have three major items like you
know Explorer or like home Explorer and
shop right and then let's say that you
allow the user to favorite so
items throughout the know or maybe even
favorite certain sections like let's say
your your sports app maybe your
favoriting certain leagues or certain
teams even what do you guys see as you
know or is it is it appropriate to use
or to show these types of items in the
navigation Drive
I think it's a it's totally appropriate
and I think those collapsible items are
a good way of structuring this content
if you think for example about an app
like Google Drive for example where you
have certain folders that you visit
regularly you could employ something
like frequency a recency scheme or even
explicit favorite scheme by by starring
a particular folder in order to
represent this in the navigation drawer
to make it quickly accessible once I get
back to the app right so I think you
know those those dynamic items are you
know a nice way of you know making
frequently needed content more
accessible yeah and on top you know the
the fact that they are collapsible if I
can add that sort of helps to keep the
entire layout clean right so sort of if
I if I don't want to look at those
options I can hide them and sort of
focus on you know the the pure top-level
navigation for example that makes
perfect sense all right Nick do you have
anything you want to add real quick
before we turn up or any I want to just
pick up on one thing that one of my
favorite lines in the the pattern in the
design guidelines says that the the
navigation drawer isn't a good fit for
every single app out there and I want to
talk about that a little bit I mean it's
kind of like the hot new thing right
it's so kind of lots of cool and
interesting apps of picking up on this
pattern and we see lots of people
running towards it just because it's
interesting so I think it's really
important to bear in mind kind of some
the guidelines the end points now like
when went
use it earlier on and also I would say
don't be lazy as all things don't you
know if you have this extra space and
navigating draw you can see that some
people might run towards it and end up
just chucking the kitchen sink in there
because they have the space to play with
and much like you're talking of
navigation talk from Google i/o where
you go through and using use cases and
other modeling tools to really kind of
look at your content to work out what
the major areas are I think that's super
important when deciding what goes in the
draw and what should you know you need
to really think about content so I
wanted to say yeah it's awesome pattern
and had some really great use cases but
it's not for everyone right yeah exactly
as you as you start to structure you
have you really should spend some time
on deciding what your top-level
navigation scheme should be and it
really should serve the purpose of your
app so if you know your top-level
navigation is all about you know spur of
the moment switching you know quick
switching between different facets you
know fixed tabs are you know the best
way of doing that of course as you have
more top levels you know you're running
out of space there then you know you
might have to do something different but
even in those cases you know if you
think about the Google i/o app from this
year for example you know you can think
about combining certain facets into one
view in order to you know still only
have three options in your fix tab so
for example the Google i/o abused
Explorer as one tab that included maps
and I think the different tracks for the
conference so here you know we sort of
took you know the the maps facet and the
tracks facet and we combined it into an
explorer facet you know and the
switching between the facets using the
tap control was still super fast and
accessible oh and our rich anything you
want to add before we sign up no I mean
I'll just echo just don't go with the
fat for the fad sake you know be
thoughtful um something we had a lot of
fun doing for the i/o talk was just
taking the Google Apps and just kind of
considering well you know what if the
app you know and love-- used a
completely different navigation
structure would that work what would
that look like would that be suitable
that's an exercise that anybody can do
kind of pretty quickly just even to
pencil sketch it out and that even if
you don't kind of want to think about it
from this very philosophical viewpoint
of how navigation should work just
drawing it out and getting you know a
gut sense of it is pretty significant
awesome well I think we've run way over
time but this is great because there's a
lot of good content a lot of new good
content a lot of things that weren't in
the guidelines that we probably should
put in the guidelines at some point but
really really glad to get you guys to
take on the navigation drawer and all
the different aspects of it so with that
thanks everybody for tuning in to a very
long episode of Android design in action
tune in I think next week or the week
after for some pretty interesting more
stuff around a Google Play I think yeah
that's it for this episode
so thanks gradients for everything